Turquía irá a las urnas este domingo en
unas elecciones denominadas como las más
importantes en décadas la permanencia
del presidente allí perdoan en el poder
se ve amenazada por una oposición que
está aprovechando la actual crisis
económica del país para prometer una
mejoría y además una restauración de los
valores democráticos y de las libertades
muy erosionadas tras dos décadas
decreciente autoritarismo moderno para
el análisis saludamos en Bogotá
Alejandro Godoy él es consultor
geopolítico en asuntos internacionales y
además docente de relaciones
internacionales de posgrado de la
universidad militar en Colombia
Alejandro muy buenos días Bienvenido a
directo a América
Buenos días Andrés gracias por la
invitación con mucho gusto cuéntenos Qué
características tienen estas elecciones
que se definen como las más importantes
del país
sin duda erdogan afronta su mayor
desafío electoral desde que se hiciera
con el poder en el año 2002 es
importante recordar que las encuestas
otorgan una ligera ventaja al candidato
de la oposición que Malú Aunque la
diferencia se ha reducido con el paso de
los días es importante además destacar
que sin ninguno de los candidatos supera
el 50% de los votos en primera vuelta se
celebrará una segunda votación el 28 de
mayo Qué marca también una diferencia
con otro tipo de elecciones o con otros
momentos que la oposición está realmente
unida los seis partidos más importantes
que incluye a los quemalistas seculares
a la derecha nacionalista A los
islamistas moderados y además algo muy
curioso incluso a viejos aliados de
erdogan como su antiguo ministro de
exteriores babacán están hoy por hoy más
integrados además tenemos este escenario
donde el pasado 20 de febrero sucedió
ese trágico terremoto con más de 50.000
fallecidos y en estas provincias hay
cerca de nueve millones de votos y lo
que menciona la y manifiesta la
oposición es que realmente no hay
garantías para saber si el censo
electoral se ha depurado y las personas
fallecidas no han sido descontadas de
esta elección adicionalmente a esto la
inflación está en un momento histórico
por encima del 42% y hay un descontento
generalizado por la radicalización de
los valores islamistas en las personas
más jóvenes este terremoto que golpeó al
país podría ser uno de estos elementos
que jugarán en contra de erdoan en las
próximas elecciones y además además de
este terremoto que otros elementos
podemos encontrar
si es interesante porque
el alcalde de Estambul creen imam Blue
el fin de semana estuvo en un mitin
político y ahí es donde encontramos la
mayor radicalización porque por parte de
los simpatizantes de erdogan hubo una
pedramiento a algunos de estos miembros
hubo bastante violencia porque erdogan
ha acusado tanto a este alcalde como al
Principal opositor que tiene él a la
principal persona que podría enfrentarse
como Defensores de los derechos de las
comunidades lgbtq más eso es algo
interesante Dentro de este ámbito y
también la oposición acusa a erdogan en
este caso concreto de no tomar las
medidas referentes para ayudar a las
personas que fueron Víctimas de este
terremoto por qué porque están gran
parte de los que buscan su independencia
están los kurdos y Turquía es un país
con una geografía electoral muy definida
las regiones de la costa occidental
votan por quemalistas O sea la oposición
mientras que en las provincias de
anatolia y del mar Negro apoyan a
erdogan el sudeste por su parte es el
territorio de los kurdos Así que es un
momento político bastante relevante para
ver si se cambian las cargas además
internacionalmente también están muy
esperando los resultados Estados Unidos
la Unión Europea que ya sabemos Estados
Unidos ha establecido algunas sanciones
específicas para Turquía por algunos
tanques que le ha vendido a Rusia Eso
hace que sea un momento bastante
llamativo y que si no como se ha dicho
democráticamente erdogan se podría
perpetuar un tiempo más en el poder
ahora cómo impactaría la ausencia de la
eventual ausencia de erdogan y también
esto En relación con lo que usted
menciona con la relación con los vecinos
también
Sí por qué hemos visto en las últimas
semanas como erdogan ha participado en
algunos bombardeos a Siria en este caso
particular también su relación delicada
con la comunidad kurda que el kurdistán
como lo conocemos es una región que
incluye no solamente a personas de de
este de este aspecto en Turquía sino
también en Siria en Irak y son cerca de
20 millones y adicionalmente a esto la
relación con occidente podría cambiar
que es como la esperanza que tienen hoy
por hoy
Unión Europea y los Estados Unidos
adicionalmente como lo ha dicho erdogan
nosotros nos hemos convertido en
amigables componedores en conciliadores
en negociadores como en el tema de
Ucrania y esto le daría un giro bastante
interesante A lo que es la política
frente al tema de Ucrania por un lado y
también a la relación con los vecinos
cuando se ha acercado bastante llamativo
la forma en que lo ha hecho a China esto
también son como las principales líneas
de actuación que podrían cambiar cierto
gas no resulta electo este domingo
Alejandro finalmente los candidatos
deberán asegurarse solamente de ganar la
presidencia también las elecciones
parlamentarias que se celebran
precisamente el mismo día
sí es importante que si la oposición
llega a ganar aunque es muy difícil
hablar que puedan hacerlo en este
domingo tendrían también que tener una
mayoría importante en el parlamento
porque si no es así no habría
favorabilidad no habría gobernabilidad
posible y los Ecos del gobierno de
erdogan serían estando presentes Mira
Alejandro Godoy consultor geopolítico en
asuntos internacionales Muchas gracias
por el análisis sobre las elecciones de
Turquía que se celebrarán este domingo
Gracias Andrés buen día y ustedes
televidentes también gracias por
acompañarnos de esta manera Terminamos
el primer bloque de directo América
quédense con nosotros que minutos
regresamos con más noticias
[Música]